[Musique]
dans la phase qu'est ce qui a même pas
fait exprès c'est pas censé être bon
normalement c'est pas ça c'est bon temps
normal moi à l'ebit à l'epim
on commence par là commence pas là
arrête de répéter répéter
mettez un cam en enfer un gamin en fait
donc tu vas tout répéter tu vas tout
répéter là tout ce que j nous répéter
tout ce que je dis ok ok arrête de
répéter tout ce que je dis mais que sa
mère de répéter tout ce que je dis mais
qu sam vénère tu chantes super mais tu
chantes super bien ok on va s'amuser on
va s'amuser arrêt de répéter tout ce que
je dis
est ok j'arrête et qu'est ce que tu fais
tu m'as demandé 50 fois d'arrêter je
devrais être content mon fils ou
[Musique]
continue de répéter tout ce que je dis
il continue de répéter
et tout ce que j'ai
trouve ça super là tu répètes carrément
tout ce qu'elle dit
au moment où je dis on devrait faire ça
plus souvent parce le meilleur moment
notre vie
des meilleurs
et colas
on devrait faire un album suit le voisin
j'ai une maison dit
produits
nathan
ça
voilà
accor
et
[Musique]
m
les gages bon bah ça lui on a piraté le
compte de multiprises parce qu'on avait
un truc à vous dire la saison elle est
finie on a kiffé faire des vidéos si
vous voulez qu'on en fasse d'autres
ébats abonnez vous et surtout on a une
annonce à faire c'est que on va faire un
truc tout sur facebook devenez sur notre
page facebook
thiais en plus y'a personne de pujol et
ce sera tout âge envie de leur dire
c'est quoi ce truc de ouf on va danser
je les dis on va danser pendant quatre
heures on va faire une offre
on vous invite donc venez vous à notre
page facebook on va faire un top de
bataille contre l'antenne
il y aura des cacahuètes